GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
MS. GOMEZ: ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE HAVE
REPORTED IN SOME DETAIL,
HORRIFYING DETAIL, ON HOW THE
PROFESSIONAL LEFT HAS TOTALLY
TRANSFORMED OF THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO FROM THIS
COUNTRY'S MOST BEAUTIFUL CITY,
ARCADE TOWN, INTO A CESSPOOL IS
FILLED WITH HOMELESSNESS AND
DRUG ADDICTION.
THAT IS NOT AND IT EXAGGERATION.
THERE ARE NOW MORE JUNKIES IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAN THERE ARE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
YOU WON'T BE SURPRISED TO LEARN
THAT THE CITY HAS ALSO BECOME
THREATENING AND DANGEROUS.
THE RATE OF PROPERTY CRIME IN
SAN FRANCISCO IS THE HIGHEST OF
ANY BIG CITY IN AMERICA.
MORE THAN FIVE DOZEN CARS ARE
SMASHED AND ROBBED EVERY SINGLE
DAY OF THE YEAR.
IT'S A DISASTER.
BUT DON'T WORRY, THE CITY'S
LEADERS HAVE A PLAN TO RESPOND
TO THIS AND OF COURSE, IT'S NOT
MORE COPS ARE BETTER ARE BETTER
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
THAT WOULD BE BIGOTED.
INSTEAD, THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO HAS DECIDED TO BAN
WORDS THAT SUGGEST SAN FRANCISCO
HAS A CRIME PROBLEM.
PEOPLE AREN'T ALLOWED TO TALK
ABOUT CRIME.
MAYBE THEY WON'T NOTICE CRIME
EXISTS.
THAT'S THE THINKING.
LAST MONTH, THE CITY'S BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DECREED THERE WILL
BE NO MORE CONVICTED FELONS IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
GOING FORWARD, EX-CONS ARE TO BE
COLD, COLD, JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS.
AS IT HAPPENS, THE PEOPLE THEY
COMMITTED CRIMES AGAINST OUR
ALSO QUOTES JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, VICTIM AND
CRIMINAL ARE NOW MORALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE.
THAT'S ON PURPOSE.
THIS IS WILKIE QUALITY.
THERE IS A PROBLEM.
IT BACK IN WASHINGTON, LEADERS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
EVIDENTLY HAVEN'T GOT THE MEMO
ON THIS.
SOME ARE SO USING THEM THE TERM,
FELON, WHICH IS THE REAL EFFORT.
SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO SEND THE
KIDS FROM THE ROOM AS WE PLAY
THE FOLLOWING CLIP.
WE WARN YOU, IT'S UGLY.
>> AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS AGREE THAT ANYONE
TRYING TO BUY A GUN SHOULD AT
LEAST HAVE TO PROVE THAT THEY
ARE NOT BEAUTIFUL OR SOMEONE
LEGALLY BRANDED FROM USING IT.
>> POLICY, MAKE SENSE.
>> FOR ALL THOSE YOUNG MEN'S, IT
MOST OF GOD, WHO GOT ARRESTED
AND ARE NOW RUINED FOR LIFE OR
TSAI ING-WEN ON THE CORNER.
>> EVERY CITIZEN HAS THE RIGHT
HAVE A GUN UNLESS YOU ARE A.
WHAT ENABLED THAT YOUNG MAN TO
GET A GUN, HE WAS ENTITLED TO.
HE WAS A PERIOD CONVICTION.
>> Tucker: SORRY ABOUT ALL THE
EFFORTS WERE AND HOW INSENSITIVE
CAN YOU GET?
MEANWHILE BACK IN THE SANITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, THERE ARE NO
LONGER ANY JUVENILES LANGUAGE
THROUGH THE WHOLE HEAD AGREE HAS
DISAPPEARED.
CRIMINALS UNDER 18 ARE NOW
REFERRED TO AS QUOTE YOUNG
PEOPLE IMPACTED BY THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AS IF THE SYSTEM AND NOT THE KID
COMMITTED THE CRIME.
WHICH IS WHAT THE LEFT IN FACT
BELIEVES.
IT'S HER FAULT.
NOT THEIRS.
CHECK YOUR PRIVILEGE, MIDDLE
AMERICA.
DRUG ADDICTS IN SAN FRANCISCO
ARE NOW CALLED PEOPLE WITH A
HISTORY OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
RATHER, USE, NOT ABUSE.
GET IT?
HEROIN ADDICTS ARE NOW THE SAME
AS INSULIN-DEPENDENT DIABETICS.
BOTH USE SUBSTANCES.
YOU CAN'T CALL ONE BETTER THAN
THE OTHER.
THEY ARE BOTH EXACTLY THE SAME.
NOW YOU CAN LAUGH THIS OFF.
IT SAN FRANCISCO AFTER ALL IS
THE PLACE WHILE THE CRAZY THINGS
HAPPEN BUT THINK OF THE
IMPLICATIONS.
LANGUAGE MAKES THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
WHEN THE WORDS DISAPPEAR, SO
DOES OUR ABILITY TO THINK ABOUT
THE IDEAS THE WORDS WERE
PRESENT.
WHEN THEY PREVENT YOU FROM
SAYING THE OBVIOUS, OVER TIME,
IT BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE TO SEE THE
OBVIOUS.